hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll here's a classic question what
is the use of Education what is the
value of being educated I'm I'm thinking
particularly here of postsecondary post
high school education College University
even graduate school and so on why do
this why get that much schooling into
you there are you know lofty answers to
this question about becoming more
well-rounded human being understanding
The Human Condition picking up reasoning
skills and learning skills there's also
socialization issues right uh meeting
people getting to know the world in a
certain way that's absolutely an
important function of going to college
but there's also a lot of down toe
practical issues right you're being
trained perhaps for a trade for a job to
become employable that's an absolutely
valid reason to get an education in the
modern world especially we point toward
Science and Technology as skills or
fields for which we would like it if
people had good training in these fields
right we invent the acronym of stem
science technology engineering and
Mathematics this is government speak or
education speak for the kinds of
sciencey techy kinds of areas that both
governments and also Al employers place
a lot of emphasis on so if you're not
within Academia right now you might not
know that there's a lot of hand ringing
and enst about the decline of the
humanities and you know the more classic
parts of the broad-based humanistic
education that we purport to care about
and too much emphasis maybe is being put
on science degrees and and related areas
but there are good reasons economic
reasons you know you want people to get
a good job that's able to pay them and
you give them a fulfilling life after
college so maybe it's fine to have a
bunch of people specializing in stem
areas today's guest is John scrne he's a
sociologist at UC San Diego and actually
someone I've known for a long time we
went to graduate school at the same time
together and used to play basketball
together as you'll find out if you hang
out for the very end here but he's
written an interesting book called
wasted education how we fail our
graduates in science technology
engineering and math the idea behind
John's book is sure employers and
governments want uh healthy and rapidly
growing scientifically and
technologically educated Workforce but
does that mean that once created that
Workforce is actually fulfilled is are
they happy do you get a science degree
and are you therefore able to get a good
job that keeps you uh having a good kind
of life and the answer not always
certainly but in uh a growing number of
cases the answer is no so it's a it's a
very interesting argument I mean a we
have to say over and over again and John
will say very explicitly in the podcast
of course certain individuals uh get
very rewarding careers out of Science
Education but we also have to take into
account those that don't and we're not
primarily talking here about people who
go into Academia or even want to go into
Academia we're talking about tech
workers which is a huge action of the
people who go from stem degrees into the
workforce they work for computing um
technology software engineering kind of
um corporations and it can be a tough
road to Ho as a matter of fact um for
one thing novelty and Innovation is of
course valued it turns out for various
reasons that we'll discuss that it can
be easier to just get rid of your
workers and hire newer younger ones
rather than retraining the existing
workers the new workers already have the
skills right they just learn them
they're fresh in their minds they're
cheaper and then a decade or two later
they can be fired and they can be
replaced it might not actually be a
sustainable way to think about our
Workforce or what it means to be a
scientist or what it means for colleges
and universities to do their students a
good service by providing them with an
education harder to come up with
solutions to this issue uh than to
diagnose it certainly it very deep
features of capitalism and our economic
and political system are involved here
but it's an important issue to highlight
one way or the other we need to know
what we're doing when we're training
people in these uh different areas that
I personally value very much but we have
to be explicit we have to be conscious
of what's Happening we we can't just say
oh science is good therefore do it it we
have to look into what happens when we
try to do that so I think you know it's
not exactly what we usually talk about
here on mindscape but sociology it's an
important part of the liberal arts
Spectrum so let's
[Music]
go joh scrne welcome to the mindscape
podcast happy to be here I'm excited to
talk to you Sean you know since we're
old friends I thought I would start you
off with a couple of softballs to get
the ball rolling here as it were uh so
what is this stem acronym and why is it
a terrible
acronym actually compared to the
Alternatives it's it's pretty awesome
really so do you prefer stem over Smet I
prefer not using an acronym oh okay well
the I I got to tell you the government
has been searching for an acronym for
quite a while and and that's because
they've been trying to count people in
these fields for quite a while really
since the Cold War yeah I I in the book
I include
a a New York Times story in which
there's this panicky headline in the New
York Times about how the United States
is falling behind the Soviet Union in
the number of technicians uh would you
would you prefer that probably not
probably not they were talking about
scientists and Engineers the National
Science Foundation has scientists and
Engineers or SN s Ampersand e so not
exactly that uh that euphonious one
might say but it appears so often in the
educational context and like no one
majors in technology that's not a thing
right right you major in science
engineering or math they're very
different from each other so I don't
like lum
so I kind of like using words rather
than acronyms yeah so the
technology I saw a government report
that used the acronym set science
engineering and technology so people
really like technology sorry you might
not like that and then there was and
then there was some use of Smet science
math engineering and technology and that
had a rationale to it where science and
math are the foundations of engineering
and technology so it you know by putting
them first it's sort of kind of a
temporal ordering of what comes first
you do the basic science you understand
the math and then you develop the
technology but smth sounds like anaman
AIA of something
unpleasant yeah oh my God a smat so it
didn't really catch on and then a Judith
ramaley is her name she was one of the
higher ups at the National Science
Foundation she apparently is the one who
coined the stem acronym just changing
the order a little bit making it sound a
little bit better and then it just took
off I I had a graduate student kind of
look who's doing research assistance for
me and she looked at the rise of the
stem acronym and it just started to
appear in bills in Congress and it just
took off and so you may not like stem
but a lot of other people like it that
is and that's a much more detailed and
serious answer than I was hoping for so
good start right so we're kind we're
kind of stuck with it and and what
exactly it means that's a that's a
different question but but stem seems to
have taken off internationally people
use that acronym they seem to understand
when I talk to them about stem so it's
stem seems to be here to stay Does it
include the social
sciences that's a good question the
National Science Foundation officially
includes UD social scientists in its
understandings of s science and
engineering and then they also talk
about stem we could go down a very
tedious rabbit hole about some of this
but they idiosyncratically I would say
include social scientists because when
most of the government policy makers are
talking about stem they're not thinking
about me yeah they're thinking about you
they're thinking about a lot of other
folks and and I can explain why that is
and and and people might protest that
that sociologists economists
demographers can be highly quantitative
political scientists as well and you
know really use Advanced statistical
computational methods so why aren't they
included in stem and I think that I
think that that has a lot to do with
what the government wants with its
investments in stem education and they
don't really want more of me I arguably
don't be offended they probably don't
want more cosmologists
either experts on general relativity
they're not saying we need more of those
give us more of those they are looking
for people
to first of all fulfill employers
demands and and these employers have
been crying shortages for quite a while
they want people to innovate they want
people you know that technology that tea
that you were so skeptical of that's
really what that's what they care no I
know that's that's I think they're
riding on my coattails
honestly they are they are and and they
they have this hope that by cranking out
more experts in stem Fields they will
innovate and they will create new
technologies that will boost American
competitiveness and boost American
National Security and grow the economy
and provide jobs for everybody I wrote
this uh book chapter a few years ago in
which I kind of traced the the history
of American policy makers and what they
wanted I'm using the acronym
anachronistically NOW what they wanted
stem workers to do obviously they
weren't talking they weren't using the
stem acronym during the Progressive Era
sure but during the Progressive Era is
really when you saw the government
trying to think about hey we've got
these experts in these science and
engineering fields we should deploy
their expertise and so the interesting
thing about the progressive era was that
they wanted to deploy the existing
expertise if we can use existing in
relation to expertise what people
already knew and and so like pure food
the Pure Food act wow we know why food
spoils now we know how to prevent food
from spoiling we know how to keep meat
safe let's keep those let's use let's
empoy that expertise and make sure that
we can make food better progressives
were real excited about you know all the
new knowledge being generated and and
they wanted to just deploy it as
strategically as possible then you had
a a sort of a change that happened
during World War II which I'm sure
you're familiar with with you know the
Manhattan Project and developing the
nuclear bomb developing radar and that
was a little bit different in the sense
that the government really wanted to
deploy scientific and Engineering
expertise to create specific Tech
technologies that they really wanted so
they brought together a lot of experts
and said hey we want you to develop a
system that can detect enemy aircraft or
hey we want you to come and develop a
system that can produce uh a weapon that
could potentially end this war the
nuclear bomb so it was very targeted use
of expertise even though they didn't yet
have the expertise so you can see we're
one step away from the Progressive Era
but by the Cold War we started to get
into a a phrase that I I kind of called
it Alchemy because it suggested this
sort of this hope that by putting stuff
together something amazing would happen
it wasn't as rational and and they
didn't the government really didn't even
have an idea of which Fields were going
to create the most Innovations or the
most the most innovations that would
create the most jobs or the innovations
that would boost National
competitiveness the most economic
competitiveness I'm talking about here
it was just this sense that by creating
more people with stem educations amazing
things were gonna happen and we don't
know what but amazing things are gonna
happen just get them together kind of
like Bell Labs maybe was a little bit
like that bring them together and
amazing things are going to happen and
um in this in
this this kind of understanding of stem
education and stem expertise it was
there was a lot of Hope in Faith kind of
a faith and I like that use of the word
faith we normally connect that with
religion but it was almost like that it
was like wow these people are Gonna Save
Us and let's invest in them and let's
make them go so techno optimism at an
early era yeah yeah that's yeah that's a
phrase that that's that's bounced around
a lot in this so so you've already
implicitly answered this question a
little bit but I'm wondering since we're
going to be talking about stem education
and what happens to people who get them
degrees it to in what sense is this a
job for sociologists to think about we
haven't had that many sociologists on
the show we had a great talk with Brooke
Harrington about offshore wealth
management but uh you know we haven't
really gone into you know enough to for
the listeners who you know I assume
listen to nothing but the mindscape
podcast to really get an idea about what
sociologists do so is this is are you
doing mainstream sociology or you kind
of branching out a little bit with this
topic that's a great question one of the
reasons I went into sociology was that I
see it as the big picture social science
uh I I think that economists produce a
lot of great knowledge I think political
scientists produce a lot of great
knowledge but I tend to think of the
knowledge they produce especially
economists as kind of looking through
the world through a rolled up piece of
paper you know creating that right now
in my with my with my hands here and and
you can see something you can focus on
something really
clearly but you don't necessarily see
all the different things that might be
connected to that thing that you're
really really focusing on right so
economists can can lead us astray
sometimes in ways that I think if
sociologists were more inclined to study
some of the issues that that economists
focus on you know they might have
provided a little bit of a corrective so
for example the world is is filled right
now with a lot of folks who are upset
about free trade and how free trade
produced a lot of economic dislocation
people running losing their jobs people
who used to work in manufacturing not
having those jobs anymore those jobs
have gone
abroad this should have been obvious and
and and I think that the economists tend
toward and sorry for any in the audience
I think they tend toward a kind of
really basic sort of
utilitarianism and so you know they
might think well we might lose some
manufacturing jobs but overall we're
going to be happier because you can
produce televisions more cheaply in
Mexico or China now these are going to
be cheaper for us to buy and and these
workers can move like water they'll just
flow around to the places where the
economic opportunities are and
everyone's going to be better off right
but what they don't understand is that
people have identities their identities
are often linked to their jobs and and
so they they struggle with economic
dislocation so sociologists I think can
look at this big picture see all these
things going on and that's kind of what
I love to do I often think of the
knowledge that I do compared to the
knowledge that you do or that you
generate I I think of the kind of
science that you do Sean is like
vertically integrated like it's really
really deep and and like if you are
focused on a problem of general
relativity I just keep bringing that up
because I know you wrote The Textbook on
it but and someone knocks on the door
and like Sean we got to talk to you like
you lose your concentration the whole
thing falls down very annoy and and then
you got to get back into it whereas the
stuff that I do and why it's hard to do
this podcast just to give you a heads up
is like horizontally integrated
knowledge it's a lot of stuff at a more
superficial level but really broad right
so I'm trying to understand you know
Investments and education and what what
Employers in software and oil and gas
and chemicals and biopharmaceuticals
like all the stuff it's just it's kind
of at a superficial
level but there's a lot of it yeah and
and I I love that though and I think it
fits more with my undiagnosed add you
know that it's easier for me to get back
into it if someone knocks on the door
because you know there's a lot of
different footholds I can grab onto
rather than that really narrow one does
that make sense do you know what I'm
talking about we did have herb ginus on
the podcast I don't know if you know his
work but it reminds me very much of that
even though he's self-identified as an
economist but uh Theory Evolution
physics it all came in and and I
absolutely see the appeal of that that's
why I do a podcast rather than just
sitting in my office W papers right
right right exactly so the sociology
when I when I when I looked at this
issue I I got a little push back from
some some stem workers themselves like
who are you what are you doing you're a
sociologist why you looking at this I
would like to think I'm the guy yeah who
can look at the big picture here I can
see things that you can't see I can
bring together different
different ideas different systems of
thought that maybe you're not aware of
and use those things to illuminate
social reality in in a unique way that
actually adds some value that makes a
contribution all right well we'll see
over the next hour whether we do that
we wow I just realized I put a lot of
pressure on myself I know you really
just set yourself up there better be
amazing so let's uh for people who are
not professional sociologists or hang
out uh there with let's set the stage
you know we have people who get degrees
in the stem and I guess the two
questions I want to ask you can address
them in whatever order is one um what
kinds of jobs do they go into right like
you know within Academia we love it when
people go into academic jobs and we
imagine getting a PhD and becoming
Professor but you and I also know that's
a small fraction of all the people who
get degrees in these fields and the
other is you know how does that compared
to all the other jobs like what is a
fraction of of people when they go in
the jobs they say oh this is a stem job
versus what management factory jobs I
don't even know what the categories are
right so that's a good question the
government talks about the policy makers
in the US government I know your
audience is international talks about
stem and nonstem as a as a binary okay
it's one or the other and there's a few
people who who go beyond that but in
general they talk about stem and
non-stem jobs and they do that because
of the what I talked about before for
this this hope that by putting people
into these stem
occupations the tra sort of traditional
stem occupations software developer
chemist biologist you know things that
you knew in high school as as science
and engineering electrical engineering
mechanical
engineering that by by getting people
into those occupations these amazing
things are going to happen in reality as
I'm sure a lot of you listen ERS know
stem and non-stem is more of a Continuum
sure I I spent a lot of time thinking
about that it ended up getting cut from
the book for various reasons but it's
definitely the case that there's a lot
there are a lot of jobs that in which
stem expertise college level stem
expertise is very very helpful so if any
of your listeners listeners or software
developers they would almost certainly
prefer a manager
who understands software
development and so there's a lot of
people who get stem degrees do go into
management a lot of people who get stem
degrees go into practicing medicine now
the government does not consider
practicing medicine to be a stem job and
really people might think yeah they
might think why is that what's going on
it's because of this thing about trying
to create Innovation okay and practicing
medicine is does a lot of great things
for people as obvious obvious for anyone
who's ever been to a competent physan
but they typically do not innovate and
create patents and jobs and things like
that we've got stem we got MD phds who
might do that but for the most part
practicing medicine is is about
deploying existing
expertise and another area where where
stem people with stem degrees will go
that are not the traditional stem
occupations is finance of various kinds
very much yeah no we're we're we are I
know you're aware of people in physics
who went into quantitative finance and
do some very high-powered things
there the National Science Foundation
data the National Science Foundation
runs this great survey called the
national survey of college graduates and
I relied on it a lot for this book it
shows that people go into this category
of of you know accountants Auditors
Financial Specialists it tends to group
them together we don't know exactly what
those folks are doing it's probably not
a lot of black schs equations and some
of the stuff that our friends in on Wall
Street do but but so that's another area
where where folks go and then a lot of
folks go into jobs that don't use stem
expertise at all and there's just too
many to mention it's hard to make
generalizations that it's a it's a very
wide variety of potential occupations
for people with with stem expertise but
I want to emphasize and I do in the book
that when the government invests in stem
OCC in stem education they want people
to go into stem occupations right and I
should say at the outset right here that
about 50% of all stem workers in the
United States are in computers in some
way right like that that's like that's
like the 800 pound gorilla of stem yeah
and we're talking software developers
that's one of the most in demand uh in
demand jobs uh you know computer
Engineers of various types people web
developers there's just a whole range of
occupations that involve computers and
one of the things that's really unique
about that particular stem sector is
that
whereas chemical firms like Dupont hires
chemists trucking companies or shipping
companies probably don't hire
chemists but computer expert of various
types they're their own Silo where tech
companies will hire these folks but then
they're also yeah like a band across the
economy where just about everybody hires
some computer experts to you know do
things run their payroll do their
Logistics I always think of trucking
because we don't think of trucking as
being very Hightech but actually they
hire a lot of data people and to manage
this whole complicated system so that
computer related Fields information
technology is a band across the whole
economy retail you know all kinds of
occupations or all kinds of sectors will
use that life sciences that'll be used
in biofarma you know all that you know
life science kinds of sectors so
computer is really the 800 pound gorilla
and um and so when we talk about stem
workers people have commented on the
book a little bit like they're saying
hey man this book seems to be really
about tech and really about computer
workers and there's two reasons for that
one is what I just told you that so many
workers go into that field and the other
reason is that those are the employers
who
argue and complain the loudest about
shortages they're the ones who are
saying hey man we need more workers
where are these workers where what's
wrong with your universities what's
wrong with you Society for not giving us
more more stemrad so that we can hire
them well that's good because that's
exactly where I wanted to go next
because I is the feeling that we get
within Academia that the humanities are
on the decline uh and stem majors are
kind of taking over is that accurate and
nevertheless there's a lot of companies
that are complaining we don't produce
enough stem Majors yeah so I I should
say at the outset that you know the book
is really about this puzzle we we
haven't we I've been talking for quite a
while here already and I haven't even
gotten to the puzzle we'll get there my
apologies
the pudle the puzzle is that there's all
these claims of a shortage of stem grads
and only According to some measures and
this is the Census Bureau only 28% of
stem grads work in stem
jobs there's different ways of counting
and different data sets my counting is
about 40% of stem grads work in stem
jobs so it's a little bit higher but
it's still a minority so the puzzle is
there's all these complaints about
shortages what's going on you know why
you producing enough and yet it's the
data looks like we're producing a
surplus so that's that's kind of the
puzzle there and is that for that that
figure those figures that you quote one
way or the other are they sort of
Lifetime like sometime 20 years ago 50
years ago I got a stem degree and now I
am or am not or is it right out of
college so basically what they
do is the national survey of college
graduates comes it it comes out every
couple years and they ask a sample of
college graduates what did you get your
degree in what are you doing now so it's
a slice of people so it includes people
right out of college and people who have
been out for a while but that's a great
question because I was really interested
in whether people kind
of go in massive numbers into stem early
on and then move on to something else
but there's there's a lot of data that
suggests even in high demand Fields like
electrical engineering that some data
suggests upwards is 50 % right out of
college say nah I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna go this stem route I'm gonna go do
something else so really it's a it's a
leaky pipeline that's a metaphor that's
often used you've probably heard that
metaphor it's a leaky pipeline that
leaks at all
stages if if we think about stem as
something important in elementary school
people lose interest there high school
college and then right out of college
and then throughout their work lives
people people can exit this the stem
pipeline that's one of the things I
really wanted to emphasize in this book
is that too many people studying this
focus on the stem pipeline is just about
education from K through 16 K through
college but really people have to keep
and we can talk about this later people
have to keep their stem skills up to dat
and and stem education if if you want to
be successful in stem you got to keep
your skills up to date education doesn't
end at College doesn't end at a PhD you
got to constantly reup you got to
constantly I I call it the stem skills
treadmill I apologize for the
transparent attempt to create jargon um
but I really wanted to capture something
here which is the idea of moving while
standing in place right stem workers
really have to keep moving they really
have to keep learning just to be able to
keep their job and um I feel like I'm
getting off uh no this is I mean that is
ultimately where we want to go but
that's okay because we can go back and
forth but just like just a drive it home
it's okay to get the point halfway
through the podcast um I one gets the
impression that a successful
undergraduate majoring in a stem field
is going to come out of college thinking
of themselves as Elite and well trained
Etc but one of the messages of your book
is it's exactly those people who the
employers think of as basically cheap
and disposable right they're use them
for a little while until their skills
are not quite as Cutting Edge anymore
and they're not going to really mind if
they just fire them and hire new
graduates right I I talked to a CEO of a
of a
stem an innovation economy sort of
company and they hired a lot of stem
workers and this CEO used the phrase
that I title a chapter of the book Burn
and churn and it was striking he he said
just so matter of factly yeah we burn
and churn through them they have a lot
of enthusiasm and we take advantage of
that and when their skills fall out of
date or when they get kind of burned out
then we hire some more and we there's
other studies that show stem employers
like to get new blood they like to get
new folks coming in there like they like
this
churn and so that's seen as as a
positive and there's not that much
concern about what happens to people get
burned out there's a lot of research
it's it's funny because for years I've
advised students and maybe you have as
well to to major in the field that
you're passionate about you know to
choose a career that you think you can
be passionate
about but leave it to the social
scientists to find something negative
about
that and there's there's new research
mainly from my field in sociology about
how employers exploit this passion oh
okay they think wow we've got these
workers who really love this and let's
you know get them to work 60 70 hours a
week we don't even have to pay them
extra because they're so passionate
they've had great teachers and
professors who fired their excitement
about this field and let's ride that
wave until it crashes or Peters out or
something and and and maybe we can then
hire the next group of passionate
workers so what leads these companies to
complain about a shortage is it just
that they want even more cheap workers
just out of college so
I I kind of played Dumb In the book a
little bit I'm like all right employers
you say that there's a shortage I'm GNA
take that at face value If there really
is a shortage are you behaving like
there's a shortage are you acting like
stem grads are scarce and valuable and
can just produce magic that's going to
benefit all of us or are you treating
these folks as as as disposable
i i i there's a lot of good metaphors
Sean that work here one of the ones I
think about is squeezing an orange
getting that juice out of it in my LA
Times oped I I suddenly thought about
fast fashion something that kind of
works or that's like really great for a
short time but you don't expect it to
last you move through it and so that's
what they do and I just kept believing
them pretending to believe them and
saying all right let's see if your
actions match your words
and they just really it it just really
doesn't the New York Times has a
headline today it's I don't know if I
can mention the date in in this um but
but it could be almost any day there's a
there's a new round of layoffs at major
major tech companies these are the firms
they they created this lobbying group
called forward us that their whole their
whole reason for being is the idea of a
stem shortage whole reason for being is
lobbying the government for both more
stem grads more stem education and also
more stem migrants to come and a lot of
these companies and and it's part of the
reason I talk about these tech companies
they they're rich you know I mean some
of these are are are near monopolies
we're talking Google we're talking
Amazon we're talking well alphabet you
know Google is tedious they change their
names Facebook's now meta but huge you
know two billion people have Facebook
they own
Instagram Apple has like a billion
dollars in cash they're they lay off
workers yeah they you know they just
we're done with you guys we don't do we
hired too many sorry we don't need you
guys
anymore I I met a guy who was a former
uh HR expert at a major tech company and
he had a brilliant idea and I'm not
going to give him credit cuz he actually
wanted to remain anonymous but he moved
into the education field like Elementary
education and high school education and
in that field for students with learning
disabilities there's this thing called
the IEP which stands for individual
education program or individualized
education plan something like that but
the idea is you have a student with some
kind of learning disability you monitor
their progress you figure out what their
strengths are you figure out what they
need to know
and and he thought that was a great
model for these really rich tech
companies that are constantly
complaining about shortages if if it
looks like and who's going to know
better than the employers themselves if
it looks like some skills are about to
be
obsolete why not tell these workers hey
you've already got this great foundation
in stem education your specialty is kind
of going going down we need something
new this looks like it's going to be the
new thing we're going to put a little
bit of money in there and we're going to
train you and deploy you somewhere else
in the
firm they they typically don't do that
they they let you go I Google um I think
it was Google was basically told
companies or told employees you've got
this many months to figure out what
skill you want to develop you're on your
own to figure that out how do you know
how do you know what's going to be the
next in demand skill and so they moved
into that you know they they were given
the opportunity to move into that but
without guidance or without without paid
training so that that's really tough I
gotta lay another metaphor on you and
this came from someone a stem worker and
engineer who emailed me after my my LA
Times Zed came out and I love you know I
love to get the the voices from the
field it's so interesting to hear their
stories this engineer told me that he
thought stemor was was something like
Prospect prospecting and Mining in the
1800s and you've got these people who
chase the chase the latest Gold Rush
yeah we're gonna go do that thing it's
gonna be really hot for a while maybe
some people are gonna get rich maybe
some you know stem workers are gonna
stock options there's going to be a lot
of stem people are going to get rich but
then it's going to Peter up and then
those folks got to find the next big
thing and this engineer told me he
didn't want his children to go into
these fields because he said it gets
tiring chasing these gold rushes chasing
these you know the next the next mine to
be exploited and and and just really
really you know people really dig into
it you know I can give your your readers
can probably think of examples but
blockchain was really huge for a while
uh AI is now the huge one you know it it
goes up and down if you're in oil and
gas you know the if the price of oil is
super high they're like wow we need more
look at we can pay them a lot and then
suddenly that price plummets and then
that goes down for people in the Life
Sciences there could be some promising
new technologies in life sciences like
right now mRNA is really big maybe
there's going to be some limitations
there Gene editing really big might be
some limitations there we'll see but you
get these fields that get super hot and
then they try they hire a lot of folks
if they don't get FDA approval if the
clinical trials don't work out see you
later and and and Life Sciences will lay
off a bunch of workers as well is is it
possible to oversimplify your argument
by saying that there might possibly be
downsides to
capitalism um I would
say that the problem isn't necessarily
capitalism per se the problem really is
is and this is where I really put on my
sociologist hat and I'm but I'm
borrowing from some ideas that come from
from economists as well there are
cultural
practices that characterize American
capitalism especially American
capitalism today and certainly over the
last few decades which are creating this
problem and there's a lot of folks
who've written about this but there's
expect
that investors have that they didn't
used to have and that is that they it
they call it maximizing short-term
shareholder value various permutations
of that phrase various versions of that
phrase but sharehold like there's
there's a whole movement to create this
thing that that the that the
stakeholders who really matter for a
corporation are the shareholders not the
employees the shareholders not the
customers not the customers as anyone
who's tried to do customer service in
almost any field any sector not the
people in the regional economy where the
company might be based it's the
shareholders and they should expect
value on their investment in the short
term and there's a lot of complicated
stuff about how this came about there
used to be these massive conglomerates
that had all these diverse sort of
companies Under One Roof underwear and
apple pie Sarah Lee owned
Haynes the Sarah Lee company you like
underwear company like all these crazy
things put together and they were doing
that to hedge them you know kind of
hedge their bets if the Apple Pi Market
collaps at least they can make some
money on t-shirts so uh but shareholders
were like no no no we want you to do
what you do find your core competency do
that thing it was a massive redefinition
of what corporations were really about
and there was a redefinition of what
workers were and workers became costs
and investors began to
applaud corporations that shed workers
this was a big shift you know you would
always have companies that would lay off
workers when the economy was bad but by
the 1980s as we got this shift to this
maximizing short-term shareholder value
kind of approach to corporations you got
companies that shed workers even in good
times and and the stock price would go
up
I I I give the example of Sarah Lee
because it's just such a it's such a
great example and and the and the CEO
complained you know that like my God you
know what the investors just want us to
get rid of workers that's what they want
yeah and you know
investors they don't like training in
the United States especially the
Europeans are better at investing in
training than the American American
corporations are why you know
sociologists like to talk about training
as investing but in investors see that
as spending money and why are you
spending money on that when you should
be maybe doing stock BuyBacks or doing
something to boost the value of your
stock so I wouldn't say it's capitalism
I would say it's this version of
capitalism that we have right now we
have similar kinds of short-term
expectations among V Venture capitalists
which I think are very important it
drives them to put their money into
software at the expense of other
Industries which I think we need very
badly in the book I'm very transparent
about what I want stem workers to do I
want them to save the planet I really
want them to develop clean energy better
Plastics uh carbon capture Technologies
there's so many things we badly need but
investors want software they love
software you know Instagram is worth a
billion dollars when it had 11
employees stagram was was software yeah
and and the reason investors love
software is because that is a from the
from the perspective of investor that's
a fantastic investment you can easily
demonstrate the technology works unlike
new battery technologies unlike things
that we badly need like Fusion Energy
you know there's some startups doing
Fusion Energy but boy when are we going
to get that can we really demonstrate
that that works with software you can
pretty much show that it works pretty
quickly you don't need a factory to
create it which is a major advantage
yeah uh if you don't need a factory you
don't need
employees you just need a few people to
do the
software um
and and and so and then you can make
massive amounts of money the the return
on software Investments are
like 10 times much percentage higher
than Returns on clean energy which is
which is which is what I think we badly
need and so investors you know they just
keep
blockchain AI is the new ones that I
mentioned but any kind of software
fintech you know technology related to
to finance social media Sur the
surveillance capitalism which is another
very you know this a term coined by
Shana zuboff you know tracking us on the
internet wow we can sell you more things
and and not necessarily have to produce
things so we don't need factories we
don't have what investors called the
Valley of Death where you kind of go
from the The Innovation to the actual
manufacturing phase which can take a
while making sure the Prototype works
and all that kind of stuff so that's a
long way to say capitalism is not the
problem I think it's the version of
capitalism that we have right now okay
and there's probably like a whole
another podcast we could devote to how
that version of capitalism came to be
but I'll we'll we'll stay little bit
focused here uh and I do want to give
you a chance to mention that the fear of
Bec becoming obsolete and then getting
fired is not the only thing that is
keeping stem grads slightly unhappy I
mean there's the overwork uh aspect
there's other things where the grass
isn't quite as green as they hoped it
would be once you've gotten your
Bachelor's in electrical engineering and
enter the job
market yeah so I I tend to think again
taking at face value these employers
that there are these dire shortages and
it's a crisis and those are the words
that they use take that at face Val you
well what are they doing how are they
treating these these stem workers and
one of the things that they do is they
incentivize movements out of stem and
they do that by paying their managers
more and I I know you're an NBA
basketball fan I know you love you love
the Sixers you've got your passions
there do you still love the Sixers we
had Daryl mury as a guest on the
podcast okay the DM of the Sixers yes
uh so it's interesting because in
professional sports the players who have
these scarce skills are paid more than
the managers right in in stem the
managers are typically not always
typically paid more than the folks who
have the skills that are supposedly
scarce yeah and and employers control
wages they can they decide how much to
pay their workers this is an area where
I I think sociologists have done a
little bit better than the economists
the The Economist they have some
theories about wages but understanding
the starting point of the wage I don't
think they've been very good at and I
think sociologists are a little bit
better at this I talked to the COO of a
tech company I'm using an anecdote here
and he was telling me we need more we
need more user experience designers the
folks who design the interface of the
software that we're using right now
and and I don't want to pay them what
they're
demanding and and and he showed me
there's these there's these services
that kind of do surveys of how much
people are paying people in different
fields including user experience
designers and he's saying look at how
much they make I don't want to pay them
more than this that's a sociological
kind of dynamic it's it's you know
isomorphism is the jargon anything but
you know we want to look like we're
doing what other folks are doing we
don't want to be someone who pays their
user EXP experienced designer too much
this this this uh this guy decided I
can't find people here to do it I'm
going to Outsource this job so he went
around the world Eastern Europe China
Mexico India looking for cheaper user
experience designers um until he found
some that he thought were competent and
he could pay them less
so and then that's you know the more
that kind of thing takes off the the
less you incentivize people to move into
that field in the United States and the
more you become dependent on Outsourcing
that thing but but a big argument that I
make in the book is that there's a lot
of self-inflicted wounds here if indeed
there is there is scarcity and the
decision to pay your stem workers less
than their
managers and to incentivize movements
out of stem which not every firm does
but it's very common it it's one of it's
one of the problems in this area well
and there is also the idea that
because there truly are so many stem
graduates that these employers can hire
that they can kind of abuse them once
they're there right that they can kind
of give them overtime uh there's these
schedules that are invented to hit
targets and really Crush people and it
can be it can be kind of uh Soul
destroying to just toil away this job
for a few years before you get
outdated I I think that that's exactly
right Sean and I I Rely pretty heav
on to kind of explore the detail of this
a ethnog an ethnography by a sociologist
named oer Chiron I want to give him a
shout out because I think he did such
great work where he spent some time at a
big tech company he had to keep it
anonimous but it's a it's a major tech
company that that folks know and that is
you know has Deep Pockets it has a lot
of money and boy they work their workers
really hard and and he he kind of
captured this thing and I I actually use
this for my in my intro to Sociology
class to kind of in my sociology of work
to talk about again the sort of social
scientist making everything seem bad but
even these jobs that are supposedly
great even these jobs that looks that
look fun and the media image of some of
these stem jobs is people playing
foosball people playing pingpong there
there was a stem employer here in San
Diego that had this big swirly slide in
the atrium of their of their
workplace
uh this elra Chiron went to this company
and saw that people didn't really use
this stuff that it looked like a lot of
fun stuff was around but people didn't
use it and that was because for much of
the Year these workers were in what they
call Crunch mode or crunch time and that
is the time when they're racing to
deliver a product that has been promised
at a for for a delivery date at a
particular time and they've got to make
sure that it works and they've they've
start working he found workers worked an
average of 67 hours a week that's a long
time yeah and and they and they did it
sort of voluntarily the the managers
have these clever ways of managing
workers
to if they didn't come with the passion
to sort of coax the passion out of them
or make them behave as if they're
passionate it it's these pretty bruising
performance reviews where every worker
is ranked it's it's called stacked
ranking or forced
ranking sometimes it's called cynically
Rank and yank where you rank of the
workers and You Yank out the ones that
are ranked in a in a low in a low
position but the workers themselves
choose their hours and they choose the
hours based on this idea that they want
to impress their manager so the manager
might go to them and say hey we got us
this product we want to deliver we want
it to have this and that
capability we need someone to do this
particular aspect of this software for
example and do you think you could do it
and how long do you think it'll take you
and they want to high ranking they want
a high evaluation for their performance
valuation so they kind of overpromise or
they certainly promise very
ambitiously because if they say h that
looks hard oh I don't know about that
maybe you should dial down your
expectations that that manager is going
to think I don't know if I want this guy
I me the obvious analogies to graduate
school can not have missed your
notice yes yeah there's there's there's
definitely a lot of analogies to to
graduate school you are absolutely right
my mind is racing right now with some of
them but trying to stay focused here so
so what you have as workers see seemly
voluntarily taking on these excessive
hours and
then working themselves very very hard
one one software developer compared it
to drinking out of a fire hose just
trying to keep up with all the stuff
that's going on and and developing the
skills that they need maybe they promis
something that involves a skill that
they don't have yet so they got to work
to develop that and and that stuff is
very difficult and one of the things
that maybe some some of your listeners
are familiar with I know some of the
some of the stem workers with whom I've
spoken are familiar with
this it's often a Young Person's game
and and part of that there's there's
reasons for that one of them is
that some young people kind of realize
wow I'm gonna have to keep my skills up
to date all the time that's going to be
hard and I can do this for a little
while but I kind of burn out and then I
move on to something else the other
thing is that older workers often have
families and if you have families they
take time
unfortunately maybe that's fortunate
that's okay it's not it's not uh it's
it's something it's a job that you have
to do and and it doesn't go away and and
these
workers they have a they have a second
shift at home if they're not shunting
that off onto a spouse and and it gets
harder and harder to self-train in your
in your in your own your own time and so
it just create it creates more and more
stress so these these deadlines happen
and and it and it does put a lot of
pressure on on workers and again this
might sound very softw very Tech focused
but but those are the employers who say
there shortages those are the employers
who often are the richest those are the
employers getting all this investment
from investors and if there's any place
where we would expect stem workers to be
treated really great it should be these
employers and and I don't think we see
that and there is there's a point you
make in the book and I wasn't sure
whether this was in your mind more
aspirational or factual but the idea
that a lot of there's some idealism in
the young stem workers they want to or
they should want to I'm not sure make
the world a better place and that turns
out not to be uh the most lucrative job
opportunity than making a world a better
place kind of
fields yeah so this is where I was able
to explore some of the issues I was a
double major in sociology and philosophy
and I've always been interested like you
in the meaning of life what is this all
for I don't get
much opportunity to really study that
but in the last chapter of the book I
wanted to really explore this question
of stem education for what what are we
what are
we what are we as a society hoping to
get with innovations that stem workers
are are
producing and I think that some stem
workers and and I want to be really
clear about this I'm sure there's some
very very happy stem workers who are
listening to this right now I hope
they're still listening and they're
thinking I love my job I'm not working
70 hours a week this is fantastic I'm
making tons of money I can retire early
there are those folks I'm talking about
the
Aggregate and there are folks who are
really excited to be working on
interesting stem problems problems
regardless of what it is some some stem
workers are and and I admire them
they're kind of pure scientists in a way
they love particular ways of thinking
and so they could move from cosmology or
astrophysics into data science and
predictive algorithms and things like
that thinking I I there's a guy I I
don't know if he ended up in the book I
may have I may have had him in there I
may have cut him out but he was an
astrophysics major who couldn't get a
job or decided not to get a job in
Academia and then he worked for a
clothing
retailer who that needed experts in Ai
and machine learning and that sort of
thing so that they could give customers
suggestions of new clothes to buy okay
now very I would find that to be kind of
Soul destroying to go from thinking
about general relativity to be thinking
about how can I get someone to buy
things that they don't
need but but from a pure science
standpoint from the pure complexity of
problem standpoint some folks can make
that
transition but not everybody right and
so there's a literature in sociology and
management and psychology about how some
jobs can produce moral stresses or even
moral injuries anyone who's seen at at
their workplace workplace bullying
that you know they might have felt a
moral stress if they've known that their
employer is someone at their job is
embezzling that could creat create a
moral stress but what I was interested
in the last chapter of the book asking
stem education for what are the stem
workers who are uncomfortable morally
with the business model of their of
their
firm and it's it's easy to pick on
social media but it's easy to pick on
social media because there's a lot of
evidence that social media produces a
lot of social
harms and so I quote some workers at at
Facebook who said Facebook is hurting
people at
scale another worker another worker
more more uh graphically said I feel
like I have blood on my hands for
Facebook's role in promoting
disinformation and pro promoting
political conflict in societies other
than the United States other people have
said well they actually promote conflict
in the United States there's new
research coming out about rises in
depression especially teen depression
especially teen girls they pretty
effective and studies are convincing
yeah there's there's evidence that
suggests hard to prove these things
definitively causal inferences are very
difficult in social science but there's
evidence that suggests social media use
is part of the reason we're
seeing very alarming rises in teen
depression so you know some stem workers
can think oh we're I'm doing interesting
things analytically these are exciting
problems to solve I'm working with smart
people they can get really jazzed about
that other workers can kind of think
when I go home at night I don't feel
good about what I'm doing here yeah um
you know they're even
like I don't know if any I don't know if
any of your you or any of your listeners
have kind of gone on these YouTube
rabbit holes where you start watching a
video and then YouTube saying what about
this one what about this one how about
that one you like that check out this
one and they they tend to lead you into
more extreme content or more shocking or
emotionally uh provocative content
there's a
phrase engagement equals enragement or
maybe you could reverse it enragement
equal engagement but the idea is getting
this emotional hook into the users by
outraging them is a way to get them to
use the app longer and so you know
Google The Google owns alphabet owns
Google Google owns YouTube they're
involved in this stuff as well very rich
company using using different
Technologies to get people very upset
and you can imagine workers not being
happy with this
well before you defended capitalism a
little bit saying that there's a
particular type of capitalism which
we've evolved to and and I I appreciate
the benefits of capitalism in in certain
circumstances markets are good at
solving certain problems but a lot of
what you're describing really just
sounds like capitalism that's gotten
better at being efficiently capitalistic
because of faster information flows and
faster decisions and more scales and
wider labor markets and things like that
whereas as a globe as as a species we
produce a lot we produce abundance and
and do we need to think radically it's
late in the podcast this is where we let
to you know get to speculate a little
bit so do we need to think more
radically about the system that lets
this all
happen I actually don't think we need to
think more radically about it I think
that we have the tools available now to
get more out of our investments in stem
education than we are getting now one of
the things we could do is create more
incentives
for innovators in the fields that we
desperately need I often think you know
if if we're all made extinct by climate
change or something like
that and you know an alien civilization
comes down and they look at us and they
think well what were you guys investing
in when the planet was falling apart and
there were pandemics and the signs were
all around around you that you were in
big trouble and if we say cryptocurrency
blockchain AI surveillance economy you
know it's G to look a little silly so I
I think some intervention is needed but
not a radical change so one of the
things we could do is create more
government incentives in investment in
clean energy uh better Plastics that
don't that don't create micro
nanoplastics that are in our bodies in
human breast milk incredibly forever
chemicals that we don't know what what
are doing with us we can create we can
create in incentives through tax rebates
or tax incentives to make these
movements happen the inflation reduction
act which is a very general name for a
very big Bill did create these
incentives and it's created stakeholders
who are are moving into the clean energy
space so one thing you can do is create
incentives for more of the Investments
we need that'll produce more
opportunities for stem workers to deploy
their skills in ways that might feel
morally resonant with
them and another thing you can do is
simply make
illegal some uses of of stem skills
there's there's a lot of debate in among
legal experts about whether targeted
advertising should just be banned so
that you remove the incentive for these
companies to endlessly find ways to to
surveil their all of us on the internet
because they can't do this targeted
advertising then they don't have an
incentive to do that anymore so you can
legislate things away and then another
thing you could do is just think
about moral limits on investors and and
business models you know cannabis is
legal in my state of Cal of
California but my understanding is the
Cannabis business is a little shaky
because banks are a little nervous
working with those folks uh there's
there's this kind of sense that they're
sort of cordoned off like whoa you guys
are a little bit different um I I
hesitate to use this word but
pornography is a very lucrative field
that's also kind of like Whoa We don't
want to invest in that you know we don't
really want what really want to be a
part of that so we already have moral
limits that shape investor behavior and
and what people are willing to spend
their time on in terms of uh business
practices and investing but for some
reason it's okay
to take away people's privacy to stoke
Division and conflict to
encourage disinformation the spread of
disinformation in
society a lot of things that you might
argue are more harmful than
cannabis you know are are okay for
investors to invest in you know Mass
layoffs which disrupt families there's a
lot of things that investors tolerate
right now which perhaps they shouldn't
perhaps a little more moral education um
could could go away here as well you
know I'm not a cannabis guy but I was an
online poker player and uh it it used to
be done by many many people and the
government swooped in one Friday and
seized all their assets and uh basically
can't play poker online now like certain
States you can but it used to just be
all over and and I agree that's a lot
less harmful than some of the things you
just
mentioned yeah so there's there's
research that suggests that you can you
can tweak capitalism you can you can fix
it in which in ways that will generate
the productive energies The Innovation
the riches that capitalism that can
produce and minimize some of the harms
that we that we see well I don't quite
so the thing that I'm I'm still missing
though is the Innovation disrupting the
kinds of jobs that people grew up having
you know if if if as is plausible the
rate of innovation and and which skills
are relevant is increasing the rate so
it's faster now we're always going to
have a an issue where people who hit 50
are no longer valued and that that does
seem a bit harder to solve I'm not quite
sure how to do it yeah so the the
national survey of college graduates
they they asked this broad range of of
of college
graduates did they take skills related
training in the past year or two and and
we looked at the time since their degree
and about 60% have taken skills related
training in stem up to 30 years after
their degree so we're getting into the
50s it starts to go down when we're
getting into getting into people's 60s
so you're absolutely right that that is
an issue so one of the things that we
need to do
is I don't like this phrase Sean because
it sounds so
1970s the lifelong learning we we had
this model of Education that you
graduate in your early 20s and then
you're gone and and we I really think we
need to to change that we're we're in a
different era now and we need a model
where we think of college as a place you
return to periodically for skills
updating or a Skilling something in a
different area altogether when your
skills become
obsolete maybe something like a
subscription model or something where
you can go back to your alma mater or a
different University but this
expectation that we have of college is
something you do when you're young and
then you move on maybe needs to be
changed a little bit I I still think
that college education is absolutely
essential for creating what I what I
like to think of as foundational skills
the basic skills that a college graduate
has one of the things is to learn how to
learn PhD training really makes you good
at that but even with the Bachelors you
kind of learn how to learn you can
discern good Knowledge from Bad
knowledge you learn how to sort of sort
through what's what's good and bad in in
in trying to find the skills that you
might need or the knowledge you might
need but you'll have that core
Foundation but then on top of that the
skills that you actually deploy at work
might change many times throughout your
career so I would argue and I'm working
on a book on this with a colleague right
now college education is great for that
Foundation but circling back to college
to get a skills updating not for another
degree but kind of a short-term
certificate kind of very specific narrow
kind of skill that can be deployed now
might be something that many people will
have to do repeatedly throughout their
careers I mean I of of course of course
I'm very much in favor of lifelong
learning I do Wonder though about the
model because
one is at a very different life stage at
age 40 than age 20 right when you're 20
not only you're learning it for the
first time but there's a certain freedom
to fail because your obligations are
relatively low but once you have a kid
and mortgages and things like that and
also you've been happy for last 20 years
doing some job I mean I I I'm in favor
of efficiency but I feel the human cost
of having to say I need to do something
different than what I've been doing
before yeah I agree with that but the
reality is the reality is upon us you
are going to have to do something
different there there was a great study
that was done you know it social
scientists love a natural experiment
where something happens and you can
something happens that's rare and you
could examine how human beings respond
to it so Steve Jobs decided that the
iPhone was no longer going to support
Adobe Flash software right said you know
what we're not GNA do Adobe Flash
anymore we're gonna use something else
and there were a lot of software experts
on Adobe Flash not necessarily employed
by Adobe but that was what they did
suddenly that was gone yeah they had to
respond so that reality is already there
where the where a skill that has maybe
been developed over a few
years is just no longer needed and so
that reality is already there so how are
we as a society gonna gonna deal with
the
the regular obsolescing of technical
skills and you're right it's definitely
hard people's identities get wrapped up
in their jobs and and they their their
skill sets get get you know more and
more fine-tuned and then to lose that
can be really tragic especially as you
say if they have a family so that's
going to be difficult I think if if
shareholders don't punish companies for
investing in the training of their
workers especially the richest companies
and for investing in their workers that
should be something that's encouraged
and applauded I got to tell you I don't
want to go off the subject too much here
but Google invests a lot of money in
schools they they give away Chromebooks
to students they do a lot of things to
get to train the next generation of
software developers at that stage but
they could do more for their incumbent
workers yeah you know that that's the
odd thing and so social scientists they
they talk about Corporate social
responsibility and some things are done
kind of as corporate branding you know
like look how good we are we give away
this money some of it's done to kind of
create market share let's get a bunch of
people using Chromebooks and they're
gonna love Google so there's there's
money that's being spent in this area
but I would argue they could do more for
their incumbent workers to manage these
sometimes sometimes very difficult to
navigate uh career changes or job skill
changes uh later in life Maybe maybe as
a final thought we can be more
idealistic ourselves because uh of
course we want people to get lucrative
rewarding jobs that they can uh have in
some level of security throughout their
career but that's not the only reason to
get an education right uh when people
ask me about applying to graduate school
in physics my line is typically that you
prob you will probably go in hoping to
be a professor you probably will not
succeed at being a professor but getting
a PhD in physics is actually an
intrinsically good thing you'll you'll
be able to do something else you'll
learn a lot of skills Etc uh I don't
feel the same way about being a postdoc
but that's a different conversation but
you where does that fit in to this
conversation just the idea that getting
a degree in stem or related fields you
know has some value whatever your future
life trajectory turns out to
be so I've seen that argument and I
appreciate your honesty when you tell
people
that the odds are the odds are they will
end up doing something different right
and I think that's an important message
to give them say yes this is a great
thing to do you're going to get some
very important skills but keep an open
mind for developing keep an open mind
toward career trajectories that don't
look like physics right so one of the
one of the disturbing findings I had in
some research with a colleague when we
looked at the national survey of college
graduates and we looked at people with
stem degrees who went into non-stem jobs
is they were significantly less likely
to report being satisfied with their
jobs overall and
interestingly they were significantly
less likely to be satisfied with the
intellectual challenge of their jobs
interesting
so a little bit less they're they're
less satisfied they seem to be a little
bit more likely to be
bored I don't feel so great about that
that and and so you know being honest
with people and telling them hey there's
a good chance you'll be doing something
else I would encourage folks to develop
a broad range of skills through we've
got this I call it stem Mania on the
book at my University Sean University of
California San Diego it's it's sort of
like a public Caltech I always thought
of it as that it's it's really stem
focused it it was born it's it is in San
dieo because that's where the scripts
Institute of oceanography was and that
sort of stem tone really kind of
dominates the university and the
students who major in the humanities and
social scientists are social scientists
other than economics regularly have to
defend themselves to the their their the
stem the stem Majors who were like what
are you gonna do with that what's wrong
with you this is
crazy and so this also sounds
self-serving but I tell my stem Majors
who do take sociology classes it is
important to get a a broad range of
skills skills related to communication
written oral critical thinking outside
of technical skills because chances are
you're GNA move into something outside
of scem stem or sort of stem adjacent
and and and college is a time to really
develop that that broad range of skills
I mean you always had that I mean you
really always stood out your double
major in philosophy and astronomy as I
recall yeah so you always had that
message but that's not typical and so
you could segue into this whole podcast
thing and you know this this whole range
of of stuff that you do because of that
undergraduate
training I'm trying to make a world of
of little miniature Sean carrols so that
they will have that flexibility to plug
into different places in the economy
stem expertise is great to have I I I
would think the best thing that you
could have to prepare yourself for the
workplace of Tomorrow is stem skill
skills and non- stem skills foundational
sorts of skills like like like you have
yeah I mean you're not going to get any
argument from me that the broad base is
important but if it's true that people
who get stem degrees report
dissatisfaction with their jobs once
they get them what is are the data about
Humanities degrees or social science
degrees no one cares about them so I I I
didn't have a grant to look at them I
didn't really look at those folks there
are I I initially wanted to explore this
there are a pretty significant
percentage different Studies have
different percentages but a good 15% you
know of stem workers don't have stem
degrees and so you have folks excuse me
you have folks who majored in humanity
sort of subjects and they moved into
technical Fields one of the great things
about software development is it's a
field that's pretty porous you don't
it's not like electrical engineering
it's hard to break into electrical
engineering Life Sciences without those
degrees but software is is wonderfully
porous you can you can be this sort of
kid who worked on a computer in high
school went and got I actually have a
friend of mine who was a creative
writing major but he tinkered with
computers in high school he developed
some some software sold it to a major
software company did really well
even though his major was creative
writing so software is is is really
welcoming to people um you can do these
boot camps where you get your
foundational skills in writing and
communication then you do a boot camp in
coding or data data analytics or
something then you can plug into the
stem economy that way so that's
definitely something that that you that
you can do so I I I applaud those folks
but for the most part people are not
worried or valorizing our Humanity's
majors and so it and and I don't want to
say we need to treat our stem majors and
our stem gra our stem grads better than
the other grads but if we say that
there's shortages of stem grads if we
say that stem grads are so important for
the economy we should at least treat
these FS these folks really well and and
hopefully treat everybody really well
but at least these folks who were
constantly saying are so important and
in such short supp
well okay I I like your final message
which is everyone should major in
creative writing I think that's a
very like wonderful world going forward
so John scrne thanks so much for being
on the mindscape podcast thanks Sean it
was great to be here and you know I just
want to end with one thing I've listened
to podcast before where people know the
interviewer the host of the podcast and
they tediously kind of say oh we had all
so many great times in the past you can
cut this out my friend but probably not
many listeners know that you were a
double threat on the basketball court
not enough of them know that you had an
a sweet jump shot from the outside I
still remember the sound of the ball
going through the net and nothing but
the sound of that and you had a you had
a pretty good drive to the to the hoop
as well if someone covered you too close
to the three-point line you could blow
by them so not many not many of your
listeners may know that about you but
that's definitely you were a a
multifaceted skilled guy and still are
sorry the past tense you must remember
that that Lefty hook shot was so
annoying to everyone else yours that
like so many people you know complained
about it that you started complaining
about them complaining about it because
they weren't used to a lefty that's
that's right but if everyone expects a
right-handed jump shot then uh the
left-handed Hook is gonna is gonna is
Gonna Keep Me keep me going for quite a
while something to remember thanks very
much Sean okay thanks
Sean
[Music]
w